hey guys welcome back to the Jenna and
Julian podcast haha um we didn't upload
a podcast yesterday so it was a holiday
so we decided that we were gonna take a
holiday from the podcasts which was nice
we enjoyed it we had hot dogs and Sam
you know sat outside got some Sun it was
lectured to me many times as a younger
person how important it is to take
vacations and then didn't really believe
them no yeah
now on that person lecturing other
people being like loosen man you get off
licking pay call pass on the torch this
episode of the Jenna and Julian podcast
is brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is yeah although easiest
ways to create your website blog online
shop they have elegant interfaces 24
hour seven days a week
customer service like great customer
service check it out Squarespace calm
and use products code jayjay at checkout
for 10% off your website we'll talk more
about that later Thank You Squarespace
JJ or J&J just JJ JJ JJ cool no need for
the end it's like extraneous but thank
you for sponsoring our podcast
Squarespace thank you for the support uh
so I don't know if you guys have noticed
we got a new lens we invested in some
new lenses for our cameras and we are
rocking a new wider lens right now so
the cameras like right in front of us
normally it would be all the way at the
end of the room because of the stock
lens when I was like 20 20 something
millimeter of the smallest so it
couldn't really [ __ ] couldn't really
zoom it it was just not a wide lens no
it's not business yet yeah um so that's
that's what we're trying out are you
citing it like it let us know if you
hate it then keep to yourself because we
like it if you hate it just say it
nicely yeah be nice about it because we
really like it um but yeah it's kind of
exciting and we got another smaller lens
to play with him yes you've had a DSLR
for years and we just got this new
camera and we only had two lenses so
it's exciting to be able to a DSLR I
literally never bought another lens he's
got a stock that came with it yeah cuz I
was like [ __ ] it no works I'm not making
fancy [ __ ] over here and now we can make
Cathy know we can
fancy shall we go me I like the lens
which the smaller one that you have the
millimeter Nikki fifty its prime lens it
I said when you put it on the big camera
it looks like a chode well yeah when
you're looking at the physical camera
yeah spoke everything look everything
that you shoot looks like a freaking
music video that's incredible fault um
anyways I thought for today it would be
fun to take the Carl Jung personality
test so I can get my phone to open oh
yeah great job phone wake up
classic phone typology test excuse me so
this is a plate we found this on human
metrics calm which is a website we
literally just googled it I'm sure
there's other places you can find it I'm
sure you can find it in textbooks
whatever you please but it basically
gives you a personality type and okay
let me just redo what it says upon
completion of the questionnaire you will
Carl Jung you for those of you that
don't know is very famous in the
psychology world for many things you
will obtain your four-letter type
formula according to Carl Jung and
Isabel Briggs Myers typology along with
the strengths of preferences and the
description of your personality type you
will also discover careers and
occupations most suitable for your
personality type along with examples of
educational institutions where you can
get a relevant degree or training you
can see which famous personalities share
your type how would they know about
though they've taken it all right let's
take this online questionnaire with a
grain of salt
so there's wait hold on be able to use
the results of this test as an input
into the Jung Jung marriage test and the
demo of the marriage tests to assess
your compatibility with your long-term
romantic we're gonna see what's up right
yeah read that part ah
baby hey long-term baby well hopefully
personalities and if not we can just end
the podcast right here kidding guys the
podcast is over our personalities don't
match there's 72 questions right yeah
there's a male and female at the end so
we'll skip that one cuz that's not
important just kidding
it's important what do you mean male and
female I was just joking we have to pick
a sex otherwise everything's [ __ ] well
yeah cuz if I answer all my answers and
I'm like female we don't have time to
fill in our gender yeah we have well we
have time for 72 questions and we don't
time for mailing him anyway great joke
Julien Jenner is a construct anyways
giant well okay then we'll go there
another all right so what I thought we
would do is read the the questionnaire
out loud if you are I guess if you're
doing this along with us although you
wouldn't get your like score at the end
you'd at least have it all filled out
but maybe play along and see how many
you get like me or like Julian and maybe
we'll talk about which ones we have
different or the same you ready right
into it question number one you're
almost never late for your appointments
yes I don't know how to answer that just
right now I'm just gonna go ahead and
say no I'm like uncomfortable being I'm
like the fire department's though
literally anything that you didn't yet
out of time got it okay number two you'd
like to be engaged in an active and
fast-paced job yes I'd say yeah you
enjoy having a wide circle of
acquaintances yeah yes I don't like that
yes makes me uncomfortable
I like having lots of acquaintances and
then only a few close friends you feel
involved when watching TV soaps well
yeah it's a good one yeah why not I get
involved watching like anything like
property brothers like invested okay
you're usually you are usually the first
to react in a sudden event such as the
telephone ring or an unexpected question
nope
every time the phone rings are the DOS
someone's at the door yeah Julian
yeah no I'm yes on that one you were
more interested in the general idea than
the details of its realization no
I need the details not any of the
details I need all of the details all of
them have me too but I feel like that's
like how can I answer that like on all
on every occasion it's that's what I'm
saying it's generalizing alright fine
yeah okay you tend to be unbiased even
when this might endanger your good
relations with people yes or no these by
the way are all yes or no questions no I
will be biased if it means saving face
in a relationship even if it's just like
a friend um to a certain degree I'm not
gonna lie all the time but I'm just
saying I'm trying to understand you tend
to be unbiased even if this might
endanger your good relation yeah I guess
I'll be biased when the [ __ ] calls
for it yeah I think so too I think a lot
of people have to say no if they're
being honest brain strict observance of
the established rules is likely to
prevent a good outcome so basically do
you like to follow rules no do you think
following the rules always leads to the
best outcome um no it says is likely to
prevent a good outcome oh so I read it
wrong yes if you're following everything
hard by the book its lightly I guess
that's a trick question though yeah
let's prevent a good outcome so by
swallowing their souls it's hurting the
outcome no I like following girls I'm
actually terrified of authority that is
Tara divided Authority it's difficult to
get you excited nope yeah now I get
excited easily it's in your nature to
assume responsibility I don't say yeah
yeah you often think about humankind and
it's destiny how do I [ __ ] [ __ ] yes I
was gonna say that's all you how do I
answer this typology test with that's
all I think about you believe the best
decision is one that can easily be
changed what is that saying that you
you're you're making like open-ended
decisions the best decision is one that
can ease no no I'm gonna say no so
that's basically saying you're you think
firm decisions are bad right okay no no
I think I think the best decisions are
ones that are concrete like yeah
flexibility
is nice but like the big decisions in
your life you gotta be you gotta be
decisive don't change them yeah
objective criticism is always useful in
any activity no no it's definitely as a
time in place I think the word always
use I think you really suck at boiling
tea and I'm gonna tell you that
yeah lick when you're working with
children yeah a great finger painting it
looks stupid you think you're gonna get
anywhere with my leg yeah you're trying
to critique their their fingers yeah
classic through just like you making my
sandwich and then you guys got something
like you're being biased in that
situation you're like hey this finger
pain is good even if it looks like crap
you're saying it's good to prevent poor
relations with that kid mmm you want a
smoother relationship with people even
if it's a toddler we're moving on though
you prefer to act immediately rather
than speculate about various options yes
no yeah that's when we are different for
sure I I'm a Virgo through and through a
moment not through in through you're an
Aries oh yeah I get a little like I need
to think about things for like days
before I make a decision but then at
least I know it's the right one
that is true for me that's true you know
yeah you trust reason rather than
feelings yes always know you trust your
feelings you know I don't it's not that
I trust my feelings more it's just that
I don't trust reason more than feelings
I think it's a balance I feel like if
this question was about like a
relationship or like interpersonal
things I would say I trust like my gut
feeling and I trust my feelings about
things yeah but just in general in life
I don't make decisions based on emotion
I try to make them based on what
logically makes sense yeah okay that's
fair you're inclined to rely more on
improvisation than prior planning how do
I click yes a hundred times on that that
means you basically force yourself to
audible all the time no I just I I read
that question as when you do things you
do them in the
rather than sitting around and having
planning on schedule yeah concrete
laughs yes I agree with on you spend
your leisure time actively socializing
with a group of people attending parties
shopping etc no okay but this question
is so complicated now because I
socialize on the Internet's that's
actually a good point
that's this test is outdated what like
socializing with a group of people if
you're considering the Internet
yeah socialize all the time but
attending parties and shopping go to
park I can't
yeah I can't I'm gonna say no oh man
attending parties shopping etc you
usually plan your actions in advance no
no I'm not calculated on your actions
are frequently influenced by your
emotion see this is where I would have
um I would um it's hard because I don't
everyone since summers day I'm gonna say
yes yeah it's like it's just forcing you
into a box here I don't like it yeah I'm
gonna feel weird volumes so boxy and
weird so boxy and weird you are a person
somewhat reserved and distant in
communication no but in what context
that's what I'm saying yeah you really
just have to take every question with a
grain of salt knowing that it's putting
a blanket on every aspect of what you do
so it could be the true in some sense of
any other yeah I'm not distant in
communication and I speak my mind not
mean you okay you know how to put every
minute of your time to good purpose no
no no I think that there's plenty of
time in the day for you to take a couple
minutes and just not have any plan and
just go spaced out member I told you I
would be I was like Julia I'm just gonna
stare at this guy I know you said a
jillion my phone's dead I'm gonna go
stare this qaida for work yeah believe
that's what I want to do I'm gonna go
space out for a little while right now I
know how to put every minute of my time
to get purpose when Wendy's is in front
of me I'm good at like planning out how
I'm going to eat like a giant meal well
I mean that's it's also a [ __ ] trick
question you know how to put every
minute of your time to good use so
doesn't mean you put every bit of your
time I use oh no your turn
you readily help people while asking
nothing in return
yeah yeah you are good people here is
true
you often contemplate the complexity of
life yes oh so hard
I'm yes to him I'm just drowning in my
thoughts about the complexity of life
everyday it's crushing it's crushing
crushing crushing me yep after prolonged
social socializing you feel you need to
get away and be alone yes very hard yeah
yeah I feel like a dog in a dog park
prolonged socialization I think that's
way more than enough socializing your
human subject you often do jobs in a
hurry hmm I mean what [ __ ] define
that yeah well because the way the word
hurry sounds to me is like you often do
jobs recklessly right and that's not all
say no but you can also interpret it as
you also are very efficient doing jobs
which one could interpret right like the
real thing happened and you had to say
yes and do it on the spot are you able
to do that or do you do that frequently
I would say yeah I say no okay you
easily see the general principle behind
specific occurrences yes no yes no I
just sometimes I just like okay I don't
get it whatever no I like I've been
analyzed I think way too much about what
everything means and why everyone does
the things that they do mm-hmm it's
weird it's not weird you frequently and
easily express your feelings in emotions
yes yeah yeah I'd say I do
I don't frequently express my emotions I
easily express my lilius max but my
emotions are easily expressed I bought
the emotion expressed
oh good want you to to jump on with me
don't we're headed over to emotion land
you what kind of question is this
you find it difficult to speak loudly oh
yes I'm having trouble no I understand I
understand that some people like don't
like to speak loudly like speak up in a
group of people or maybe a volume or
whatever and I'm gonna go ahead and say
no and say no I'm gonna go ahead
number 29 you get bored if you have to
read theoretical books
oh no never no ever um theoretical in
your board from that mm-hmm you tend to
uh you tend to sympathize with other
people yes
yeah sympathize and empathize
I never thought both both you value
justice higher than mercy no no that's
something an evil person would say no
but there's lots of people that think
like you know the laws the law that's
true never sees what people Justice what
am I saying I mean we watch an awful lot
of s for you to understand why Olivia
Benson you know in Stabler they cover
some [ __ ] up sometimes so that people
you know get what's right instead of
just with the Lannisters
mercy Julian mercy you rapidly get
involved with a social GD what would
Olivia Benson do can we make the shirt
sure is there like a copyright
infringement there probably but what if
we read Benson what if we when they ask
what worse it was that what were B
stands for we'll just right Benson but
spelled wrong that neither were
copyright free but it actually says wwbd
Julian at any point and any day at any
time you can take a shirt and get a
marker and make any shirt ajumma okay
good you rapidly get involved with the
social life of a new workplace no I'm so
bad at that and I always feel like I'm
completely like not in not in this
circle of oh you guys had like three
happy hours in the last week and I don't
know about it it's very like 40 year old
virgin for me yeah well you guys know
you guys are hanging out again tonight
okay I just want to buy these and take
them home so it's a we're the more
people with whom you speak the better
you feel no that's a solid no for me and
I know that's not like that's not
popular I feel like a lot of people feel
better when they talk to a lot of people
I like to internalize I'm I'm gonna say
no to that also because I feel like it's
better to maybe have a quality
conversation with one person because the
the question relies on the more people
with whom you speak
yeah yeah cuz if I have one good
conversation I don't want to go talk to
anybody else about it even to me yeah
for sure that doesn't make me feel
anybody makes me feel weird
yeah I agree you tend to rely on your
experience rather than theoretical
alternatives yes yeah we are approaching
question 35 which is about halfway
through if we could do really quickly
have a word from Squarespace Ted squares
yeah like I said thank you thank you for
thank you for sending these but the the
spot the sponsor this week in the
podcast is squarespace.com and we talked
about it last week a lot but there's so
many ways to create a website and for
years it's been not an easy thing to
make a a website and be make it look
good and now with Squarespace not only
do you have all the tools to make your
website look exactly how you want but
you have all the tools to customize it
you have the ability to make it work on
mobile you have online stores coming
with it you have customer support you
have problems you have questions they're
there for you literally 24/7 on chat and
I mean you look at some of these
templates and they look professional so
you sitting where you are whatever you
do for a living or for your hobby if you
want to start a website a blog online
store Squarespace comm has some of the
best-looking and easiest most functional
website templates you'll be very happy
if you try Squarespace at
squarespace.com like I said you get 10%
off building your website by using the
product code jayjay for Jen and Julie
which is jayjay and let us know your
experience because honestly I've seen it
and it's amazing like we were thinking
about even hosting the podcast on
Squarespace eventually like because they
offered you know they send but it's like
some of this stuff on Squarespace does
not look like anyone can do it but you
can anyone could do it so sure this
website that we're on right now could
use scripts oh this looks like it's in
1995 and also I was thinking about the
ARB reader where we got Kermit from and
yeah she can you scratch Lois uniques
gravy always check out Squarespace I
mean you love your dogs but you love
your dogs and we did our research you
guys are legit but I mean yeah that's
and that's another thing looks like
outdated you have the ability to choose
from so many templates that all look
really good which one fits you and
customize it move things around and have
it work on mobile and have people like
when you go on a website and it looks
clean it's easy to use you're like yeah
I appreciate that
come on when you my money doll I give
you my money this looks clean I want to
go here even if we're not buying stuff
so squarespace.com thank you Squarespace
for sponsoring alright number 35 as a
rule you proceed only when you have a
clear and detailed plan um I'm gonna say
yes unless you know I'm gonna say yes
that because that's I don't know there's
there's times when I do things I don't
have a plan for which also contradicts
me not being a planner but somehow it
makes sense in my life I think generally
I feel like I have a mini checklist in
my head that allows me to go forward and
a detailed plan isn't something on that
checklist you know what I mean
yeah or the checklist a word that's
hanging me up those precede like I feel
like sometimes I do things that are
whatever but if I'm like going for lower
yeah something I don't do it unless I
need a plan I think I'm pretty pretty
reckless sometimes but that's how a
pizza dough got number 36 you easily
empathize with concerns about people yes
you often prefer to read a book than go
to a party well I'm gonna say no to that
maybe maybe you know a couple years ago
I mean if that said like play video
games then it's a win mortal kombat yeah
maybe so I go on reddit ah maybe
networks yes look no you know what let's
imply let's think that they implied
other than a book or do you really think
we should stick with this book just
stick with okay fair enough you enjoy
being at the center of events in which
other people are directly involved what
so basically you enjoy being the center
of attention and where a lot of people
are involved I mean no not let me not
protect you I don't like to put myself
in situations where I'm just gonna be
the center of attention I mean obviously
it's plural obviously things happen and
you move into career paths where people
watch you like we're doing now but it's
not like we enjoy it or we look for it
it's good yeah I'm thinking about
anything that I've done like beyond
myself or like youtubers or whatever
like when you do a big bigger project
and there's all these people around you
I'm
yeah I don't like this man yeah I don't
like that yeah you are more inclined to
experiment than to follow familiar
approaches I like to experiment me too
me too my experiment I'm dull with this
hair and just make up don't let me um
this look that I have on my face right
now it's called I woke up like this by
Jenna you avoid being bound by
obligations is I like to try as hard as
possible I would say yes I would say
you'd be probably asked to for that
right yeah you are strongly touched by
stories about people's troubles yes tiny
violin no I just care yeah it was a hard
deadlines seem to you to be of relative
rather than absolute importance oh you
said this paper was due Friday well is
that relative no no okay I feel like
I've lived 10 lives because deadlines to
me in college and that we're absolute
and I was never late on anything so back
then you said no but now in my actual
life I feel like deadlines can be
changed according to like now what's
more important in your life yeah I mean
like we said like with the other ones
it's it's I would say yes to this
question in some instances and no to
other instance okay yeah I say yes to
that particular question I would say no
that their relative rather yes yeah I'm
saying yes just the word deadline I mean
I wrote for a good newspaper and like
the word deadlines was so like burden to
my brain that I can never even take that
lightly so right no that's deadly well
we're also uploading this podcast after
you're right see there you go that's
what I mean though like in a general
sense the word deadline to me means like
Givaudan but then you're right like we
are late sometimes you prefer to isolate
yourself from outside noises like the
dogs barking yes is that is that
figurative or literally I don't [ __ ]
know me and this quiz is like way harder
than I thought
gonna be yeah it's kind of weird no I
like outside just not the dogs barking
but that's normally inside anyway it's
essential for you to try things with
your own hands yes big time you think
that almost everything can be analyzed
yes I have a problem yeah I think mmm no
I think some things are not meant to be
analyzed you take pleasure in putting
things in order yes wait what question
are you on your honor I skipped one well
for you no surprise is better than
surprises go to our bad ones
these are you just saying you don't like
surprises
I enjoy surprises whoop yes surprises
are fun dad or good ones [ __ ] zest of
life alright so I skipped ahead but you
take pleasure in putting things in order
yes
yeah but although my life is usually not
in order and when I do put it in order
it gives me a great sense of pleasure
ya know I when I start cleaning things
up around the house and I have like a
clear workspace I have a clear head
space so yes you feel at ease in a crowd
oh my god how can i no harder today
should I get like panicky at like
football games and stuff like that I
don't like it don't like him in you have
good control of your desires and
temptations no I don't you probably do I
do I don't because I love me some trashy
reality TV show and I have no control
for him but those those are included in
my design coming that means I have back
Joe okay oh yes oh yes you easily
understand new theoretical principles
yes no yes yes no no scoff scoff
sorry did you say the word scoff scoff
the process of searching for a solution
is more important to you than the
solution itself yes that makes me a very
not mathematical person but yes I need
to take a second oh [ __ ] I really feel
like the when you have a problem and you
and you like the way that you go about
solving it that is what makes you better
at solving problem
later on like the the solution is is an
instant gratification you get the
solution at the problem soft but when
you have to be uncomfortable and have to
scramble a little bit to find the
solution I feel like that process is
what no I would agree with you
completely I was trying to think of
scenarios where maybe that wasn't true
so I'm gonna say yes also to that but
I'm poking it around you usually place
yourself nearer to the side than the
center of the room yeah yeah probably
who the [ __ ] just stands in the Miller
hey guys I'm here get out a seat bro sit
down when solving a problem you would
rather follow a familiar approach than
seek a new one no I wouldn't you never
fought we need when solving approach
it's Eze like ok so like here's an
example um I don't know I'll give you an
exam yeah give me an example my car
broke down one time ok and it was like a
holiday in like the middle of upstate
New York where there's like nowhere to
go and I had two options I could because
of the entire like exhaust system fell
off my car and was sparking behind ok
and so I called my mom cuz I was like
halfway like probably three hours away
from Rochester and she was like just
call triple-a pull over someone will
come and get you like three hours from
then then they would take it in who
knows how long it would get yes yeah get
home probably a day or two late yeah
instead I went into my truck I grabbed a
rope I tied the entire exhaust system up
slammed my truck so that stayed up I
found a like an auto body shop that was
open on this holiday and there was just
a guy there and he offered to fix it for
me so you're okay so you basically are
telling me that like thinking on the go
is but is better than going to a
specific like plan every time I think
that the question the way that it is
when solving a problem would you rather
follow a familiar approach than seek a
new one I think that sometimes if if I'm
following familiar approach and it's not
working I'd rather seek a new one yeah
but you did exhaust the familiar
approach no I didn't I didn't call
triple-a because I decided I didn't want
wait there and be a day or two late so
this is another question where I would
feel like yes sometimes and no other
times but I guess it just comes out of
what you would pick more because I hear
what you're saying that's the way that's
the protocol for when your car breaks
down you call a tow you call a tow truck
okay but think about this like you're
editing a video and finally about
crashes and you lose everything you that
happened like a month ago and you did
this thing where you went back into your
backup and you found it or that's
existing that's a familiar of exactly so
are you gonna just there's also been
plenty of times where I've half shot a
video didn't like it and instead of just
trying to fix that I just shot a new one
okay but I mean I don't think that's
really the same situation I'm gonna say
no but let me say yes you try to stand
firmly by your principles yes yeah I
would say I mean oh God okay yes a
thirst for adventure is close to your
heart yes I I'm gonna say yes even
though flying isn't I think if we could
take up flying skiing if we could take
flying and skiing then [ __ ] yeah which I
don't enjoy flying I love skiing so very
different if you guys ever want to ski
just text me she doesn't go so I'll just
come with you I don't ski you prefer
meeting in small groups over interaction
with lots of people yeah me too me too
when considering a situation you pay
more attention to the current situation
and less to a possible sequence of
events so basically no are you living in
the moment
are you happier well I have now in my
thought and my thought process is flying
so if I'm flying do I pay more attention
to flying or like a possible sequence of
events no I'm thinking about our
sequence of events constantly yeah I
don't know I fell asleep on a plane
dreamed about the plane crashing into
the city that we were lavich wig landing
and woke up we were still flying
Chetta it's gonna be okay I don't like
fun I know you don't when solving a
problem you consider the rational
approach to be the best yeah yeah I
think so too
you find it difficult to talk about your
feelings no we already established a lot
of feelings yes so many feeling she
doesn't even go here you often spend
time thinking of how things could be
improved yeah yeah I think so you
decisions are based more on the feeling
of a moment than on the thorough
planning what so if you're planning a
party per se you go with what you're
feeling right now no you're going with
how you want the party to feel like
rather than like I mean it corks I need
to get the essence of that yes
yeah I'd say yeah cuz it doesn't really
matter at the end of the day look if
you're planning a wedding link isn't
really matter [ __ ] goes also all that
matters is that you're gonna have a good
time I'm also like feeling is one you
know you're very familiar with your own
feelings so if you use that as like a as
a reference point to make something
happens I mean this this [ __ ] test is
just designed to make you the biggest
hypocrite yeah I guess I guess you're
right you prefer to spend your leisure
time alone or relaxing in a tranquil
atmosphere yeah if the couch is tranquil
then [ __ ] yeah yeah I would say yes you
feel more comfortable sticking to
conventional ways no no no no no no
you're easily affected by strong
emotions well aren't we [ __ ] on
strong emotions no I'm not no I'm no
television is I'm an ice queen I'm Elsa
[ __ ] let it go let it go my ice [ __ ]
Castle you're always looking for
opportunities yeah [ __ ] yeah you're
Dench Wow
your desk workbench etc is usually neat
and orderly no yes because I can't
freaking think when my desk is not in
order
I can't either that's why I can't think
ever you should get your desk a toner it
works wonders
as a rule current preoccupations where
are you more than your future future
plans yeah I don't sit and worry about
what's gonna happen in the future I can
get nervous about it that's kind of know
your current preoccupations where are
you more than your future points yeah so
yes mmm
I'm plenty worried about what's
happening right now I don't have to
worry too much about yeah I would agree
yes you get pleasure from solitary walks
yes definitely I love but with dogs yes
is that allowed yeah it's easy for you
to communicate in social situations yeah
I'd say yeah
no I'm not bad but I'm just not great
you're consistent in your habits yes yes
you willingly involve yourself in
matters which engage your sympathies
yeah hmm I mean yeah sure yeah I don't
want to think about it yeah it's gonna
my brain starts like trying to
understand what we got the last question
okay we're gonna make it we got don't
get hungry go number 71 my browser
crashed hi just kidding oh my god you
easily perceived various ways in which
events could develop yes yeah okay your
age oh [ __ ] oh it's just like a scale 22
24 25 to 29 male score it how come they
only have male and female that's [ __ ]
up mhm mhm score it okay how do we uh
should I read mine first
okay my type is FP introvert 33% sensing
1% feeling 75% perceiving 11% you'll
have a moderate preference of
introversion over extraversion 33% you
have a marginal or no preference of
sensing over intuition 1% you have
distinct preference of feeling
overthinking 75% Wow okay you have a
slight preference of perceiving over
judging 11% you may keep going there's a
whole lot of stuff sure well I don't
really know well why don't I read mine
yeah that looks the same yeah read the
same so then okay
I am INFP apparently I don't want
immense introvert 22% curve which means
you have a slight preference of
introversion over extraversion I think
that's fair yeah sometimes I would
rather I'm a little more introverted
I'm moderate yeah I'm 62 percent
intuitive you have a distinct preference
of intuition over sensing I don't really
know what that means though intuition
and sensing there kind of I mean I feel
like sensing is more an immediate area
don't really complain 50% feeling you
have a moderate preference for feeling
overthinking see that surprises me yeah
um you have a slight preference of
perceiving over judging that's the same
for me at web 20 22 22 percent okay um
so then below it there's like how do you
leverage the type why don't we pick like
one or two to look at oh you oh the
bottom ones need a free trial oh come on
oh oh come on I thought we have already
something going here all right why don't
we look at the career choices okay click
it yeah okay career choices four years
three years already
yeah radiology technician Oh nursing
medical records administration wit early
childhood education religious education
counseling what is happening wait what
there's comments on this page how do
they see this okay I don't think I did
no Julian you're supposed to be a nurse
hey hey I got two friends are nurses
shots at Jeff and Glen my boys I know
they also lift very heavy things yeah
yeah the manliest men are no guys are
more alike than you thought you were
speaking of which guys you gonna come
over and hang out at wait I miss you
guys
um so mine were okay wait
yeah do you didn't even read your thing
overall INFP no this huge thing oh the
paragraph yeah are effective in
occupations involving a lot of
intellectual work that is focused on
humanities and social science spirit and
soul inspirational activities and
requiring creativity social workers
psychologists life coaches addiction
rehab counselors mental and community
care staff children education teaching
also creative script writing and some
examples that are occupations for Dianna
own creative script writing I'm
analyzing what I did I study psychology
to teaching did all of that no camp
counselor I was a nurse and I work lips
to the dark side in religious education
I know you were that's my background a
lot of people don't know jobs word
literature and writing humanities
graphic design and multimedia our p
ology anthropology religious education
psychology and counseling you teach
Church together
to believe your personality types we
just get into religious yeah well we
should just have a topic on a podcast of
religious education not um no but like
the graphic design thing I would be
interested I feel like I'm a little arts
you know I'm artsy sort of you know I'm
intrigued by art and yeah but that's not
your yours what you got graphic design
well you did your son the same
personality type no no I'm jealous can I
be a graphic designer too wait you
serious no spirit um early childhood
education that's pretty adorable
ooh famous personality types JK Rowling
has yours so does John Lennon and
Florence Nightingale
in Princess Diana you've willin William
Shakespeare Oh slay yeah I think you win
this this whole podcast slay mm ooh
Beethoven like I somehow feel like you
won you can't win I want to see more
celebrities this is a weird website
Squarespace help these guys out this
website sucks it's pretty interesting
though right no it's very interesting
I'm glad I did it
and there's um we will link the the
website in the description so you guys
can take this and then comment and let
us know yeah there's all different kinds
there's sixteen personality types
yeah and they all start with either an e
or an i which is extrovert or introvert
yeah and I think that it's interesting I
know a lot of people cat rific has done
a little bunch of these on her YouTube
channel but a lot of internet people get
introverted yeah and then forget like
when we're thrust in front of crowds of
people that we we don't always know how
to act
I get kind of nervous yeah okay so the
way that you get the letters is ease
extroverted I is introverted sensing or
intuition thinking or feeling judging
and perceiving that makes sense yeah
so I'm INFP no I'm just gonna get a
tattooed across my face when you help
people and what understand me better why
does your right butt cheek FFP on it FP
um but this was fun I'm glad we did this
yeah just one of those things race what
else what was the other thing that we
could look at you can also look at
yourself awareness and personal growth
the rest you need to upgrade yeah you
need to pay money you do more oh thanks
um this is cool though right it was fun
I would take it again and maybe change a
couple answers but no I think it's cool
I want to read about mine infps never
seem to lose their sense of wonder one
might say they see life through
rose-colored glasses that's me see way
too excited about it's as though they
live at the edge of a looking glass
where mundane objects come to life where
flora and fauna take on mere human
qualities INFP children often exhibit
this in a Calvin and Hobbes fashion
switching from reality to fantasy and
back again with few exceptions
it is the nf child who readily develops
imaginary playmates oops oh that's right
too far Jenna oh it's too real no it's
too real
and whose stuffed animals come to life
like a whole paragraph this is my
childhood though my mom would like they
would laugh at me over the baby monitor
because in my crib I would make all this
stuff the animals line up around the
edge and then move them one by one like
oh I thought I was gonna go really dark
I think I feel like I would talk to like
imaginary friends no want me no talk to
us if they're both well that's not that
bad
I would you can ask my mom she said that
they were laughing at me over the baby
monitor all the times I was in there
just your mom would be sitting there
watching it Thank You cousin I've always
been a firm believer that if I was like
locked somewhere alone for a really long
time I would just be really fine cuz I'm
just
little bit to imagine you're so cute
though you don't want to read about
juice I did know like I don't know fun I
don't go back to the or don't go back to
your original results it's no oh you did
you already X out of it no do I go back
yeah but it opened up a new webpage no
no no I didn't open up a new page huh oh
here we go
yeah how do I do it personal growth this
one read about shows mm is FPS are the
first to hear a different drummer may
may eagerly plunge into new fashions
avant-garde experiences hip trends some
even setting the trends more in touch
with the reality of their senses than
INFP counterparts isfp is live in the
here and now their impulses yearn to be
free you know that's true about nature
and are often loosed when others was
loosed me often lost maybe when others
least expect it loosest that's what
they're trying to say there's a
misspelling right here
the isfps who continually repress these
impulses feel dead inside and may
eventually cut and run oh that's kind of
weird to do so I hope I don't cut and
run and just leave these uh this
competitive nature also seen another SP
type sometimes fosters lucky gut
feelings and willingness to take risks I
think that's pretty accurate
yeah it is pretty accurate I'm pretty
running gun shut about a [ __ ] nurse
man religious education what I don't get
though if I'm a nurse how do I get to be
more impulsive like that seems a little
weird
no but I mean it's true when you think
about it because they have to act very
impulsive extremely high stress high
stress no I actually make a game-time
call I see where they're not sure I see
where that makes sense
I like this right this is uh this is
cool
Kevin Costner also is like me and so is
get ready John Travolta slay okay we
need to keep you as far away from
Scientology as possible yes I won't be a
Scientology ferryman
like so interesting Yogi Berra should
really do this is really interesting to
like learn about yourself
Magic Johnson infps have the ability to
see good in almost anyone or anything
even for the most unlovable the INFP is
want to have pity their extreme depth of
feeling is often hidden even from
themselves until circumstances evoke an
impassioned response now Oh
INF teeth intps blah blah blah I'm
getting all these letters confused huh I
feel like we're getting kind of
confusing because you guys don't see
what we're seeing ya infp struggle with
the issue of their own ethical
perfection performance of duty for the
greater cause an INFP friend describes
the inner conflict not as a good as good
versus bad but on a grand scale good
versus evil mmm
saw dramatic doldrum mother um
marbles stop snoring fluxional Jen's
like body Noreen oh I thought more Oh
famous infps Homer Virgil yeah Mary
Mother of Jesus how do they [ __ ] know
that she took this test on the website
that's how long this website's been on
exactly you right you right William
Shakespeare fill in Keller's Palin
[ __ ] Keller yes who Helen
Keller who stop it oh my god Wow Wow Wow
Julianne Julia Roberts the star of um
these are later sellers yes no the star
of gravity the star of the one with the
dark hair Julia Roberts yes yeah that
one for those of you that don't know
what we're talking about you should
watch our Julianne sucks it's celebrity
Chara
she's in the movie get smart with Steve
Carell oh my god right oh my god we got
the election ol person oh my god all
right that's not too funny we should we
should get it anyways you should cut
ourselves off this was really fun was
what we did this and um we'll put the
link in the description yeah do it it's
definitely with what to this look I said
yeah but we were reading each question
you can do it faster than that
very fast but don't speed through it
y-you got to speed through stuff in life
like that I'm just kidding you guys you
guys are great thanks for hanging out
today and thank you to swear space for
sponsoring the podcast you guys can
start a free trial no credit card
required to begin creating your website
at squarespace.com free trial and if you
end up paying and getting a real website
used product code JJ to get 10% off your
website awesome websites awesome
templates great customer support
Squarespace calm thank you for your
support and thank you guys all for
hanging out with us through the podcast
this was a fun one
next time we'll do the one to see if we
like each other ain't nobody got time my
phone's gonna die yeah your phone is
always gonna die so it's mad
thanks Apple watch I will say goodbye to
the podcast we'll see you guys next week